Guys, before we go any further and before we get, you know, jump into this, get started,
I want to explain to you and stress the importance of the fact that the money is actually made
in picking the city and the niche combination.
And I really, really mean that it's super, super important.
And so I'm going to use an example from physical real estate.
The reason I like to use examples from physical real estate is because we are doing the exact
same thing, but doing it digitally or doing it online.
We want to become digital landlords.
So there's a saying in physical real estate, and they always say this, okay, and by they
I'm talking about the books, the experts, the gurus, the investors, and they always
say the money is made in the buy, not in the sell, okay?
What does that mean?
It means that if you're going to go purchase a, let's call it a duplex or a single family
home for $200,000, okay?
If you go and you buy a property, a duplex, let's say, that's worth $200,000, but you
purchase it for $160,000, you immediately are going to win.
Even if you turn around and you sell it for market value or below market value, you're
going to win because you immediately got $40,000 of equity, right?
You bought it for $160,000, it's worth $200,000.
You're going to win no matter what, and likewise, with digital real estate, if you pick the
right city and the right niche combination, you are almost guaranteed success, okay?
So there's a couple of reasons why this is super, super, super important.
All right, reason number one, by choosing the right city and the right niche, you are
going to be able to avoid very competitive, heavy SEO.
Nothing gets more tiring, nothing burns you out quicker, nothing is more frustrating than
just chugging along and doing backlinks and content and this and that and the rest.
It's very, very frustrating, and especially when you know you could put the same amount
of time into another niche and city combination and yield much higher results.
You could get ranked much quicker.
Number two is by not having to do heavy SEO, it's going to allow you to rank your site
quicker, and the quicker you can rank your website, the less money you're going to have
to spend on ads, the less money you're going to have to spend on ads, the more money you're
going to put in your pocket, and I think, at least me, the reason I'm here is I'm trying
to make money.
All right, number three is by picking the right city and niche combination, you are
going to be able to find areas where your cost per click on Google Ads, and we're going
to get into this, don't stress it, don't freak out if you don't know what that means, and
that's called CPC, but this is very, very simple stuff.
I'm not going to go into it right this moment, but you're going to be able to find cities
and niches where the cost per click is very inexpensive, and what that means is if it's
inexpensive for you, it's going to allow you to get more leads, in theory, for less money
out of your pocket, which means the business owner is going to get more leads by you spending
less money, which means they're going to be happier, and you're going to be able to retain
them longer.
So a huge benefit of picking the right city and the right niche combination is you're
going to be able to find those combos where you're going to find inexpensive ads, and
that is going to make all the difference in the world.
Trust me, and I have done this correctly, and I've done this incorrectly, and when you
do this correctly, it is night and day difference, okay?
Lastly, by doing this correctly, and it kind of goes back to what I said in the beginning,
doing this correctly almost guarantees your success.
If you can pick a city and you can pick a niche where there's low competition, there's
good search volume, meaning people are looking for that service, there's low cost per click,
means inexpensive advertising, and there's people that are willing to pay for your advertising,
say willing to pay for your leads, let me say it that way, you are almost guaranteed success.
Now, obviously, you have to put in the work because I can't do it for you, but these are
going to eliminate all the pitfalls that most people run into, okay?
And I will tell you this, I have done this incorrectly, and when I first got into rank
and rent, I took a couple of programs, and these programs, they told me how to pick my
city and niche, and maybe at the time that was more up to date, maybe I didn't listen
100% correctly, but I do a pretty good job of doing that, of actually paying attention
and doing stuff exactly, and I did it the way they taught, and I'll tell you that about
four weeks ago from the time of recording right this moment, I went through and audited
all my sites, and I went and I got rid of 125, 125, 125 of my websites that I built years
and years and years ago, that it's going to take me months, if not years, of just solid,
heavy SEO to even consider getting ranked. On top of that, my advertising is going to
be expensive, and for me, it just wasn't worth the squeeze, okay? So, from somebody who's
made the mistakes, do not make the same mistake, do not make the same mistake, take your time,
I don't care if you need to look at 100 city and niche combinations to pick one, I do not
care, it is worth your time, because if you can pick these winners, if you can pick these,
what I call layups, it's going to make everything easier, okay? And I'm going to show you an
example of a project I did, this has been a couple of years ago, and this thing has made me
an incredible amount of money, I put very little work into it, and it continues to produce over
and over and over. Okay, so guys, the project that I did, it was in a city called Bentonville,
Arkansas, and this is a city where it's the headquarters of Walmart, but what's interesting
is this only has a population of 52,000, and we're going to get into the population metrics
and all that kind of stuff and why it doesn't really matter, but it doesn't have a ton of
people that actually live there compared to other cities, right? So anyway, I just wanted
to point that out, but I went in and I built a project in a city called Bentonville for concrete,
okay? And as you can see, I am ranked number one for this term, at least, right? I'm not
probably not ranked for every term, but pretty dang close to it. I'm ranked number one here,
I'm also the number one in the maps, and you can see there's so few competition in this,
there's so few competitors, sorry, that I'm the only one ranking, okay? And so this is what's
crazy is if you look at this website, it's a very, very simple website, but if you actually look at
the backlink profile, you look at the content, you look at what actually went into this, this
isn't that impressive of a website. And what I'm trying to show you, if you do this correctly,
you can skip a lot of the other work, and you can make a ton of money. And from this website
alone, I have made over $20,000 over the past couple of years with the same exact client
paying me every single week on auto pay. So guys, I'm telling you right now, do not, I repeat,
do not breeze through this, skip through this, rush through this. This is so crucial that we
get this piece right, because it's gonna make all the difference in the world between being profitable
and wanting to bash your head through a wall.